these are black figs they are suited to
slow cooking roasting better than the
green figs because this outside skin is
so durable this is an amazing way of
roasting figs and it's so easy yet so
delicious lay your figs out in rows take
some rosemary and just peel that down
get that really nice fragrance them get
your scissors trim the edge almost we've
got a bit of a sort of sharp point bring
your three figs together and just thread
the top of each fig nice and gently rows
me works wonderfully with sweet dishes
as the figs roast in the oven the stalk
will impart a lovely subtle flavour
usual dust the figs with icing sugar
then coat them with a generous splash of
balsamic vinegar leave them to sit there
for five minutes
they sort of marinade I know it sounds
odd to use vinegar in your dessert but
trust me it gives the dish a fantastic
sweet and sour taste I'm gonna make a
really nice camel four or five
tablespoons sugar now flatten that out
and get it nice and even when the sugar
is even caramel cooks evenly it's
changing now you can see it melting from
the outside in one thing you don't do is
shake the pan rapidly and sit almost
like sort of a lake defrosting and it's
hitting to the center
bubbling still not dark enough yet
it's getting there turn the gas down and
stay in control
let the sugar melt until it turns a dark
amber color the secret behind any good
camel is just stopping it from
overcooking lovely take that off the gas
and all the butter in there just gently
whisk in the butter is cooling the camel
down you'll see it changing color to
like a cafe au lait
next add a glug of the balsamic vinegar
nice
beautiful that nice dark richness of the
camel little touch of water in there
that way the camel doesn't go too thick
now put the camel back on the heat take
your fix and sort of place them in
gently lovely and then just add all that
lovely little manner mmm don't waste
that it's amazing stuff they're nice and
sugar
Boston vinegar there's something so
tasty
baste those figs because the skin gets
nice and crispy on the outside and the
fig sort of just absorbs the camel
delicious so easy
now into the oven 194 10 minutes
almost doubled in size now look at the
color on them
these smell is incredible
onto your plate a lot heavier because
they've actually started absorbing that
can now douse the figs with camel and
serve with ricotta cheese the freshness
of that ricotta goes brilliantly well
with the figs we've finished that now
listen zest and then some little nib de
almonds and the rich creamy jam texture
of a fig with the ricotta okay brilliant
that is an amazing way of slow roasting
fruit and taking figs to a completely
new level
honey glazes the poor beautifully
counteracts against the left spice in
there fresh lemon juice over and that
just gives that extra acidic kick